last the century the bigger the better
this century the good the better your
story your drive your passion your why
is how you win against the big companies
I don't believe I should have to be nice
to get somebody to give me something if
my product is good no matter how I act
you will pay for it rise and shine it's
an espresso time what's up believe
nation at 7:00 my one word is believe
and I believe in you I believe you have
Michael Jordan level talent adds
something and I want you to find it
embrace it and use it to make a
difference so let's start your day off
right together grab your coffee and sip
on today's message focus on quality not
size over to you Jack Ma last a century
the bigger the better this century the
good the better do the business not
because the size it is not necessary the
big size you are the more profit you are
you really believe that I believe that's
a different we you know we got a fortune
500 companies you you judge because of
the size how many of them are really
happy how many of them profit no small
companies they're very profitable
they're very happy they can spend time
was the wife and a husband and kids
traveling around and that's life okay so
this is a clip with Jack Ma talking
about how big companies can stay
relevant and competitive why do you care
as an entrepreneur why is it on this
channel what I want you to recognize
from this clip is that big companies are
scared of you it's so often that
entrepreneurs we come from a scared
mindset we think that we are scared of
the big companies that they have the
reputation they have all the money and
they have all the resources and who are
we to compete with them they're scared
of you you have to use that to your
advantage your story your drive your
passion your Y is how you win against
the big companies so often I see this
happen so often entrepreneurs looking up
to the big companies to model best
practices and yes you can do that but
you're taking the wrong thing you think
that in order to win you need to be
corporate and professional and so you
look at their website and say here's
what the McDonald's website looks like
so here's what we have to make our
website look like you look at whoever
the big company isn't in your industry
and say we need to look like that
because that's what a winner looks like
meanwhile customers who are trying to
compare you versus other companies in
your space if you look like a junior
version of the biggest company in the
industry why are they gonna go with you
the only reason to go with you is based
off of price if you have a lower price
and that's the last thing that you want
to compete on as an entrepreneur if you
look exactly the same as the giant
company in your industry from a
marketing perspective your website your
Instagram your YouTube if you're
creating content in the same way that
these big companies are cuz you're
trying to look professional you're
trying to look corporate you lose I'm
gonna go with the big company because
they have the name brand the recognition
the traction the history why am I gonna
go with you because of your story
because of your heart because of your
soul that's why I go with you so you
need to tell your story you need to get
it out there I look at a company like
McDonald's I had to look up who the CEO
of McDonald's does anybody know who the
CEO of McDonald's is it's a guy here it
is named Steve Easterbrook Steve
Easterbrook is a CEO of McDonald's one
of the biggest brands in the world not
to hate on Steve but who knows who Steve
Easterbrook is you are not by McDonald's
because of Steve Easterbrook so don't
try to be like McDonald's because people
will buy from you because of you I want
to know your story I want to know why
you got started I want to see some heart
and soul injected into every piece of
content that you ever create into all of
your marketing putting yourself front
and center is not an ego play it's not
about you showing off and being boastful
by me understanding why you're doing
this it connects me because people love
to buy from people not big corporations
people want to feel like they're treated
like a person not a number you don't get
that buying from a giant brand this is
how you win as an entrepreneur and so my
specific piece of advice that gets
started there's so many things you can
do but how do you get started look at
the about page on your website
I want you to go to the about page on
your website you can look at mine it's
seven chemical calm slash human I want
to see personality I want to see soul I
want to know why you started this
business I want to feel buyer passion
energy I want to see a clear difference
between you and the big companies it
doesn't mean you can't be professional
you could still be professional just
don't be corporate and don't be boring
you are not a boring entrepreneur you
are on a mission to make the world and
your industry
a better world and industry so let me
feel that that's gonna attract people to
want to buy with you and to spend more
with you than some big company because
you connected with their heart and soul
and not just their brain you have an
advantage as an entrepreneur and I want
you to walk around with confidence and
pride not being the I'm the little guy
and I suck and these big companies of
all these resources they're afraid of
you you have the advantage now let's see
it and step number one update your about
page make me feel something when I visit
it now I've got a really special bonus
clip that I think you're gonna enjoy but
before that question of the day I want
to know what is it about you that is so
special so different so unique compared
to the big company your industry why
should I buy from you instead of the big
company in your industry let me know
leaving the comments below I'm curious
and I think it's gonna inspire the
people as well so leave it in the
comments thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso and enjoy the
bonus clip
let's pray so give me go
I don't believe I should have to be nice
to get somebody to give me something if
my product is good no matter how I act
you will pay for it you know that's
another principle that I learned in the
street when people want their drugs
they'll line up but get told what to do
they'll be yelled at
they'll be talked to get in the back of
the line I'm only taking 20s don't even
coming in with a dollar that kind of
thing no one's nice today
the drug dealer don't have to be nice
his work got to be good and that applies
exactly in real business as long as your
work is good people will come when your
work isn't good you have to have
gimmicks right so in the streets you got
two four five three dollar bottles
chicken bags but usually the works not
good right so in this world when you
overcompensate when you don't have good
work you overcompensate with the tension
you start to become like you sell
celebrity that's what you leverage so
now your game becomes going outside
being a slave to what everybody else
thinks
and that's another rhythm that I didn't
want to abide by as well like I wasn't
gonna be about that celebrity all I want
to do is be about good product good work
be respectful make an honest living and
work with honest people and all and the
Internet has made it really possible to
do that because again you can make your
product you could promote your product
you can sell your product you collect
the data and have that relationship
directly with your consumer the secrets
of longevity it's it's honestly not a
secret at all it's common knowledge out
there for anybody that's willing to
accept it and abide by it quality that's
it you can't base what you do around the
trend you know around what's what's hot
currently because the second the second
that that's not current no more you're
not current no more the second that
that's not hot no more you're not hot no
more so for me it's never so much been
about a specific genre of music or a
specific kind of song
it's just quality music and good songs
that's that's the really the only secret
like I don't care how old you are I
don't care where you come from or what
you did before at that moment but the
second you hit them with that record
that hits them here you're in and that's
that's really all it takes just just
make sure that you are on the pulse of
what it is people need to hear not so
much what they want
because it's get what you want what you
need is two completely different things
you'll want something to you what until
you don't want it no more what you need
never goes anywhere and riot was an
ambitious endeavor for us to say the
least but it was a pursuit of passion
we've always loved video games and we
saw an opportunity to do things
differently and improve the traditional
model high quality high production value
video games had always been this
packaged goods business but we thought
online and multiplayer centric games
would be better as online services than
as packaged goods why did we need to
sell discs anymore
who who buys any of their digital media
their other digital media like music or
video at the store versus downloading
and why did games need to cost 60 bucks
we could make them available for free
and then just sell optional content a la
carte and players could opt in only if
they saw value this would shift the
burden onto the quality of the content
and the experience and games on discs
were static like movies games could
would get printed and then the
developers would literally move on into
the next project or sequel so we thought
game should have live development teams
dedicated to evolving the experience
into reacting to user feedback we wanted
to build a company that saw the world
through the eyes of gamers and had a
commitment to quality and a relentless
focus on the player experience if you
tell yourself a story long enough you
start to believe it don't you believe
you act like I am Tulsa what a wail out
of a handcuffed lightning though Thunder
in jail now you know I'm bad over the
last week I've murdered a rock into the
stone hospitalized a brick I'm so mean I
make medicine sick the fundamental key
to success is it can take between 18 and
250 four days of taking action for a new
habit to stick I've created a new course
called 250 for confidence or every
single day for 254 days I will be
sending you a video between 30 seconds
and 5 minutes long that you start your
morning with around making you feel
confident it's absolutely free check out
the link in the description below to get
access